ich bin auf dem weg zum notar
148.000 euro an in diesem moment kommt
ich habe gerade die schlüssel um was
soll ich sagen ich hab ne wohnung
[Musik]
was für ein traum es geht tatsächlich
endlich los ich befinde mich wieder in
unsere ein zimmer wohnungen die in den
nächsten wochen und monaten umgebaut
wird und heute gehts endlich ans
vermessen damit wir überhaupt mal wissen
mit was wir es hier zu tun haben die
viel platz wir haben wo was geht und wie
wir die wohnung umbauen kannst das ding
ist glücklicherweise gibt es im prinzip
fast keine tragenden wände also die wand
die quasi den wohnbereich dem großen
raum hier vom küchenbereich und vom bad
ab trend ist nicht tragen die können wir
einfach rausnehmen ob wir das wollen ist
eine andere sache aber wir hätten die
möglichkeit das bedeutet auch hier wurde
der einbauschrank ist geht es quasi bis
hin zu einer tragenden stelle direkt
anfahren nur noch mal zum überblick hier
ist der eingang hier ist das bad hier
ist die küche und hier ist der große
raum groß das ding ist wir wollen jetzt
natürlich so viel platz wie möglich
heraus wurden ganz so oft habe ich in
den kommentaren gelesen wenn du mich
eine fußbodenheizung ein bauen willst
und so weiter das ist ja überhaupt nicht
rentabel das lohnt sich eigentlich gar
nicht und klar das ist mir bewusst das
ding ist das hier ist ein traumprojekt
das ist ein konzept es solche vielmehr
darum gehen was möglich wäre wenn geld
keine rolle spielt und das beste an der
sache ist nicht nur ich werde hier in
dieser wohnung rum plan sondern ihr auch
und es gibt tatsächlich was ziemlich
leisten zu gewinnen bevor wir dazu aber
kommen jetzt erst mal ans vermessen das
ding ist mittlerweile geht es ziemlich
einfach entweder mit so einem tollen
ding hier ein lasermessgerät wird sie
ziemlich günstig direkt im baumarkt und
haben wir auch schon beim gros umbau
genutzt oder sogar mit dem handy wenn
man ein leider sensor am iphone hat
lässt sich direkt quasi ein 3d modell
von hier erstellen und damit statt mir
jetzt gucken wir als erstes mal wie
lange die wohnung wir haben ganz genau
6204 millimeter das bedeutet ziemlich
genau 6,2 meter in der länge und in der
breite
3689 mm also ziemlich genau 3,7 meter
das ergibt eine quadratmeterzahl von max
und während ich das ganze hier mal
provisorisch eintrage komme ich dazu
warum wir jetzt hier ins spiel kommt das
ding ist ich glaube ich habe schon eine
ziemlich coole idee was ich aus der
wohnung machen will wenn direkt sollen
wo vielleicht wenn wir hin sollen sowas
kleiner woraus größer gemacht wird das
ding ist aber wir haben ja den vorteil
der schwarmintelligenz weil wir
natürlich ein paar leute zuschauen und
ein paar leute zuschauen die deutlich
schlauer sind als ich oder zumindest
deutlich mehr plane von
inneneinrichtungen und innenarchitektur
haben das habe ich schon gemerkt wenn
eine menge leute von euch geschrieben
haben diese was studieren studiert haben
oder tatsächlich das vollzeit arbeiten
was mega mega cool ist aber auch auf der
anderen seite gibt es natürlich bestimmt
leute die sich einfach dafür
interessieren vielleicht noch gar keinen
plan haben aber einfach gute ideen haben
weil sie eben nicht festgefahren sind in
irgendwelchen schemata wie man für
gewöhnlich so eine wohnung in
architektur mäßig einrichtet also habe
ich mir überlegt dass wir alle gemeinsam
daran arbeiten also schon jeder für sich
aber dass wir insgesamt alle ideen die
aus der community kommen und gemeinsam
anschauen und ich einen eigenen plan
mache und dann gucke was bei der
community so rumgekommen ist das
bedeutet ich schaue mir nichts bei euch
ab ihr könnt euch aber auch nichts bei
mir ab schauen sondern wir können alle
komplett frei ideen für diese wohnung
hier in den raum werfen
[Musik]
und dafür ein paar kriterien die ich mir
überlegt ich möchte möglichst viel platz
aus dieser wohnung raus holen ja ein
wirklich cooles experimentelles
raumkonzept haben ich möchte die wohnung
möglichst hell haben ich möchte sie
möglichst wohnlich haben und ich möchte
sie tatsächlich auf möglichen hochwertig
legt also keinen besonderen wert auf
rentabilität wie gerade eben schon
gesagt sondern auf hochwertigkeit also
das ist wirklich einfach nur ein
ideenkonzept dieses ding was aber dann
tatsächlich in die realität umgesetzt
ist also so wie man sich selber wünschen
würde auf kleinem raum in der stadt zu
leben also wirklich hier raus ein
luxuriöses kleines appartement zu machen
ich werde mir für meinen plan jemanden
an meiner seite holen der mich nicht bei
der raumaufteilung unterstützt aber beim
3d modellieren damit wir uns das hier
nachher dann wirklich bestens vorstellen
können ich habe euch alle informationen
die grundrisse und so weiter in die
videobeschleunigung getan und wir machen
eine community challenge daraus und er
hat bis freitag kommenden freitag 18 uhr
dieses datum zeit eure pläne eure ideen
einzureichen also völlig egal wie gut
ihr in irgendwas hat oder ob die
erfahrung hat macht er gerne mit fünf
coolsten ideen mit dem coolsten pläne
werden dann im nächsten video gezeigt
und die community also ihr kann
abstimmen welche dieser 15 am q smart
und der gewinner bekommt irgendeinen
preis da werde ich mir noch irgendwas
ausdenken entweder kohle oder irgendwas
was man wirklich gebrauchen kann und
damit wir möglichst genaue informationen
bekommen mache ich jetzt noch mal den
leider aus kenn ich zeige euch auch wie
das geht es ist eine free app und das
funktioniert unheimlich gut und ich
hoffe dass jetzt vorführeffekt mäßig
auch gut funktioniert ich drücke aufs
kennen bewege das handy und er erfasst
die wände erfasst die türen fast die
decke und ich laufe jetzt hier erst mal
rum und probieren dann möglichst genauen
scan zu machen
[Musik]
den vorderen bereich habe ich schon
gescannt jetzt machen sie noch einmal
den großen raum und hoffe dass die leute
die wirklich ahnung davon haben um das
benutzen wollen sie dann zusammenfügen
können aber ich glaube das sollte
funktionieren weiter geht es ja das ist
so heftig alter
das ding ist ich wette es gibt
irgendwelche firmen die sich das
unheimlich gut bezahlen lassen so scans
von unsere wohnungen zu machen und das
geht auch einfach mit dem iphone mit
oder 99 cent also auch das findet ihr
alle serbien geschlossen
das ding ist allgemein habe ich mir
überlegt dieses format diese komplette
serie eher ein bisschen blog mäßig zu
machen und nicht so komplett
durchzuplanen die ich sonst in videos
machen das hier ist wirklich meinen
traum spaßprojekt und ich will hier
tatsächlich hand anlegen und selber
designen und selber rausreißen und
selber sachen machen und da bleibt
einfach wenig raum dafür sachen
durchzuplanen es kommt wie es kommt und
ich hoffe euch gefällt das also lasst
mich unbedingt in den kommentaren mal
wissen was ihr davon haltet wenn ich das
meer so bloch mäßig machen und sobald
ihr dann ein paar leute mit mir auf der
baustelle sind jetzt mit sicherheit auch
ganz lustig es gibt allerdings auch noch
ein zwei kleine problemchen und dafür
verlassen wir die wohnung bleiben aber
im haus und gehen gemeinsam in den
keller
[Musik]
der keller ist trocken zumindest nach
meinem geruch jetzt hier nicht an als
wäre hier wasser oder schimmel drin
deswegen war es gut den motiven dabei zu
haben er hat mir das auch noch mal
bestätigt und es natürlich mega gut so
einen großen kellerraum zu haben wenn
die wohnung so klein ist damit man noch
ein paar sachen verstauen kann wie groß
das ist jetzt auch noch aus und dann
können wir auch zum eigentlichen problem
und zwar befindet sich das eigentliche
problem hier hinter verschlossenen türen
ich komme nicht rein denn zu meiner
wohnung gehört keine waschmaschinen
platz es gibt nur begrenzt
waschmaschinen plätze hier im haus und
meine wohnung hat keinen das bedeutet
theoretisch müsste meinen mieter oder
meine mieterin oder wer auch immer dann
immer raus gehen und im waschsalon ihre
wäsche waschen das ist nicht so leist
und es gibt ein paar lösungen nicht mehr
überlegt habe und die erzähle ich euch
jetzt zwei optionen zwei optionen die
mir jetzt als erstes mal so in den kopf
gekommen sind entweder ich finde eine
miniatur waschmaschine ein wasch
trockner kombination und bekommen die
irgendwie in diese mikro 25 quadratmeter
fläche rein das ist eine option ich
glaube aber nicht dass das so richtig
umsetzbar ist weil einfach unheimlich
viel platz flöten geht denen wir viel
besser gebrauchen können und die
waschküche ist ja da das bedeutet
eigentlich müssen wir den platz in der
waschküche nutzen wir haben aber kein
platz in der waschküche das ding jetzt
eigentlich stimmt ist nicht so richtig
in der waschküche gibt es noch einen
platz ein platz der unbenutzt ist auf
der anderen seite gibt es aber acht
wohnungen in diesem mehrparteienhaus die
lust auf diesen platz haben und bis dato
keinen habe und jetzt kommt ein genialer
einfall also genialer ist müsst ihr in
den kommentaren sagen aber es gibt ja
acht personen acht parteien die gerade
definitiv raus müssen in den waschsalon
um dort ihre sachen zu machen ich würde
diesen platz nehmen und für die
allgemeinheit zu einem fairen preis dort
unten eine waschsalon waschmaschine
einstellen so dass die leute zumindest
nicht mehr aus dem haus gehen müssen und
ihre wäsche zu waschen also quasi ein
wasch trockner industrie wasch trockner
und hinstellen bei dem man weiß ich
nicht für wie viel geld zwei euro pro
waschgang seinem war sachen waschen kann
das ding jetzt alle acht parteien
könnten dann einfach im haus waschen ich
würde in vorleistung gehen und diese
maschine kaufen und hätte potenziell
aber auch die möglichkeit damit
langfristig da ein bisschen gewinn zu
machen will sich so ein ding wirklich
amortisiert hat also quasi selber wieder
refinanziert hat dauert das jahr mit
sicherheit
da weiß ich nicht wie teuer die sind ich
weiß nicht wie viel man pro waschgang
wirklich nehmen kann und dazu müsste ich
erst mal die anderen eigentümer davon
überzeugen wir diesen platz zu geben im
prinzip würde ich aber alle acht
wohnungen die gerade keinen platz haben
damit aufwerten und es eine coole
optionen um das zu machen muss jetzt auf
die nächste eigentümerversammlung warten
das als punkt vorher mit anbringen und
dann wird von allen eigentümern eine
stimme abgegeben und ab weiß ich nicht
wie viel prozent wird dem entweder
stattgegeben oder auch nicht das ist
aber wie ich finde eine ziemlich coole
option wir können schauen ob wir es
hinbekommen ob wir die anderen
eigentümer davon überzeugt bekommen ob
das gewinnbringend ist aber all das
machen in den nächsten folgen genauso
wie eure vorschläge zur wohnungs
aufteilung anschauen klickt auf den link
in der video beschreibung ladet euch
alle pläne runter ist gestern ein
bisschen drin rum bald eure ideen da
rein ich bin super happy über jeden der
teilnimmt über die links in der video
beschreibung findet ihr alle
informationen teilnahmebedingungen
gewinnen und so weiter also macht mit
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
vielen vielen dank für euren support
lasst ihr video ein leichter und dann
sehen wir uns in den nächsten videos
wieder cous cous cous ich bin unendlich
kommt auf dieses projekt
[Musik]